[Music]
give me your lunch money news no one did
that to me when I was little take it
from me you have lunch money our parents
pay prepaid for the get the tickets
yeah the ticket blue ones not in high
school yeah high school they had the
yard lunch we were that rich we weren't
able to afford high school cafeteria
food that's so expensive
why do you come off like a dollar
tomorrow I got buried being she's broke
like a buck yeah not at high school it
was like some warming dude oh you went
to Santa Barbara yeah it was a Blue
Ribbon School okay what's Blue Ribbon
it's like recognized by the state of
California as being like good test score
I thought it was an ice cream company
nobody thinking beer pops Blue Ribbon oh
yeah PBR yeah yeah no we had a
restaurant class that I actually took
one year where they would we would make
gourmet food restaurant class in high
school and that's dull yeah we cooked
like recipes and stuff and times out
what kind of food did you have during
lunch like whatever the restaurant class
means you'd spam and [ __ ] pickles or
whatever because you weren't a rich kid
I guess oh yeah the cafeteria by the
cafeteria had like different a different
menu every day I mean they'd have like
the normal pizza but that was like five
dollars right and then we had pizza we
only had Pizza Hut bread stain and it
would have like like some crazy pasta
dish or something like camp like
specialty hamburger gourmet hamburgers
and whatever the restaurant class made
damn we had subway but it wasn't subway
it was just sandwiches and they used the
subway wrapper we were in and out
sometimes those are the truck key no
that's so sick so cool we had that too
submitted by Victoria to lunch ladies
have been charged in a half a million
dollar scam what no way yeah to lunch
you know what I thought was always
genius though is a lot of the food's
gets thrown away I would have saved that
[ __ ] and [ __ ] resold it to resold
they have those programs I'll find out
I'll find a buyer have you ever seen
dumpster diving documentaries no you
have it no okay so like gross
surprise yeah grocery stores they have
to throw out their food even if it's
still good because there's like like a
padding in the expiration date just to
make double double double double sure
that none of their customers get sick
and so they throw out perfectly good
food and so there's dumpster-diving
cultures that people like there's a
whole community it looks like Extreme
Couponing but then it's like these are
even more extreme because I'm a big into
trash and the and the documentary is all
about like they're like we're just
normal people it's just free their food
is good and they show you like they
justify why it's totally fine but then
they invite some friends over for dinner
and like in the documentary and the
friends like this he's kind of off she's
like oh it's still good don't know I saw
that she remember yeah she was crazy
would you ever do it if you were like
really no down'n know these ladies would
dumpster dive and then they give you the
oatmeal they found in the dumpster and
it's gross as [ __ ] and everyone thinks
it's gross but they have something
psychologically wrong with them so they
think it's like taste good because of
the value they got well it's like
chicken do you guys go based off the
expiration day or your own senses my
senses tell me to expiration I look at
the expiration and then if it's still if
it still looks off then I don't eat I've
eaten eggs over a month old Wow after
that spring turkey like that was over a
year old
anyway on top of it no a beet oh thank
you I don't eat was it frozen oh that is
Asian thing there's me that if you
freeze it lasts a long long time yeah
but I go based off of smell if it smells
wrong throw it away it's psychologically
[ __ ] me up like if I see the expression
yeah
there but I'm like yeah I did about
water but even if they even if they like
they just told it it's padded already
like they already know like maybe after
the expiration yeah still gotta go or if
the expiration is still okay but I
haven't even moved it or touched it in a
while I'm [ __ ] I almost never look at
expiration date in this case I look at
it as I threw it away as after I ate it
already and I was like oh god damn yeah
that's me too
how about water yeah the bottles expired
they have to though they're not supposed
to know have you had okay since I drank
a water that I left somewhere in my room
once like forever and I'm just like oh
it's fine and it wasn't already open it
was never open smells like all I can
drink this and I taste it tasted
disgusting so I'm like okay now I
believe what do they have was an
arrowhead water cuz there you go
was it the plastic taste no it was like
it was like plastic mixed with like must
eNOS cuz just cuz it tastes bad doesn't
mean it's bad it wasn't open with brandy
like I heard the crack oh but just cuz
it tastes as me is bad yeah but that's
your body warning you that it's bad no
cuz its water so it's good how could it
be bad no plastic the plastic was
probably what made it go bad or like
something that got in the water that
grew how did these ladies make money oh
I'm glad you're interested so this lady
here so there's these two sisters lunch
ladies a sister sister I'd want family -
yes other what about 67 the other one 61
good for them Thelma Louise they have
both been charged with larceny and
defrauding a public community because
they stole four hundred seventy eight
thousand five hundred eighty eight
dollars from 2012 to 2017 but the police
say that this could have been going for
more than 15 years but they were advised
to limit the investigation to five years
due to statute of limitations they still
four hundred thousand was half a million
and how did he steal it so they were in
charge of the daily deposits made at the
mansion in Wisconsin did they stockpile
it or they spent it as they went that's
a good question I don't know that's a
one bedroom house in LA yeah well you
know which fast money comes fast
behavior they
went to the strip club and do all kinds
of cocaine yeah when you catch Richard
you all a [ __ ] yeah
females yeah so what they would do is
that periodically throughout lunch they
would go into the cash register take out
the large bills and put them away
that is very mafia-like behavior why was
called skimming
yeah there's why would they do the large
bills because the small bills I feel
like are more stealthy yeah so they were
saying that at one of the schools the
average daily deposit from 2013 to 2016
ranged from $18 to $33 per day I mean
that makes sense to take the larger
bills and then they start in 2016 they
started documenting cash intake
differently and that went up to 93
dollars a day for a 20-17 year and then
in 2018 one of the sisters had left for
the second half of the school year and
the daily deposit average was a hundred
and eighty three dollars a day so jumped
up from 18 bucks I just remembered we
had this dope burrito cart at our school
now like it only came not every day was
like every liked like twice a week maybe
and it was this burrito lady and she
made the promise burritos they were like
these fat burritos and they were only
five bucks and you would like split it
with your friend so it was like are you
stoned right now cuz that was a STONER
story and reaction to what to say you're
continuing a conversation from 8 minutes
ago
yeah that's what I do that's that is
like Joel move I know that feeling
though so I'll let you do it
thank you Joe
sometimes you got a story that must be
told I know I would didn't want you guys
to think I never bought a burrito
from the dope-ass Maria belated we were
we were convinced though that you were
poor and you didn't so we moved on now I
want you to know and you said bye though
our pizzas was like only rich people
food but then you said that five dog
burritos totally different story the
slices were this big
the burrito was fat it was huge and so
you could chop it and still like beast
totally full dollar pizza slice how dare
that because we had personal yeah it was
Ted dollar was it knows five dollars
maybe ten pesos then I was like a dinky
slice of dogs born in Monterey Park
that's an Asian thing dude it is but
this one I said I was split with a
friend so it was like 250 each and it
would it was enough burrito for both
people oh I see how you were for 58
slice it in half that let me ask you
this Nicki yes in elementary school do
you remember a thing called papal bull
no damn paddleboat yeah is it a tostada
it's it's it's a tostada fill with
cheese sprinkle with ground beef on top
I thought it was a sauce we had actual
tostadas like fill with everything no
it's like a little shell that looks like
did you type in times like a bow please
oh you know what they started doing
those with the groceries I thought they
called it a chalupa taco boat so those
are like good like Taco Bell yeah they
stole that the grocery store they have
like Tostitos ones that are like that or
whatever big taco shells final edge oh
sorry about that shit's bomb I miss it
but it was just a shangela effect it
never happened white cheese and then
ground beef yup I googled that area taco
boat yeah yeah it looked like that was a
hard shell is what you're talking about
yeah I've never seen that you never had
that was so good
oh I remember these square pizza
those are good I like to spare people
they were soggy though they were talking
it was hating those dude the [ __ ] that I
ate at home was nothing compared to the
cafeteria that's true that's how my life
was
I love cafeteria - I loved it
compared to me - I mean my mom made some
good stuff but like laughter she broke
her leg I just ate frozen dinners after
that so I was like dude this shit's way
Ballmer
Oh sisters by the way this is the older
one
she got a must leave alone why but
they're stealing honey yeah they stole
half a million in five years but they
are old and they need it what yeah I'm a
school dog yeah they're stealing from
children half a million dollars I
thought it was just from the I guess I
just thought the cafeteria was a
separate entity actually she's not wrong
it was from the cafeteria fund it was in
front directly affecting the school like
a teacher okay then I'm sure that's fine
[Applause]
[Music]